blut vitamin b12 von chlorophyll das
alles sind moleküle aus der natur mit
wirklich wichtigen funktionen aber sie
können noch viel mehr und zwar im
bereich technik sie alle bauen auf einem
bestimmten organischen molekül auf und
genau dieses sorgt für sensationelle
erfolge wenn man es in elektroden von
batterien eingebaut denn dieses molekül
steigert die ladegeschwindigkeit von
batterien erlauben ihr habt euch dieses
thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt
jetzt alle wichtigen facts wie genau
verkürzen diese moleküle die ladezeit
der akkus so kurz und kann dadurch die
bislang so umweltschädliche
batterieherstellung nachhaltiger werden
das alles und viel mehr jetzt den klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich ein dauerthema denn das
nervt wirklich alle smartphone besitzer
und besitzerinnen täglich immer wenn
gerade ein wichtiger anruf reinkommt
oder man eine nachricht versenden will
macht das akku schlapp dazu kommt die
gefühlt so unfassbar lange und lässt
siege ladezeit der akkus deswegen
berichten wir immer wieder mal von
forschungsteams weltweit die mit
innovativen ideen dieses akku problem
endlich lösen wollen die weltweit
verbreitetste batterie technologie
basiert auf lithium ionen batterien
eingesetzt in laptops kameras handys und
fast allen anderen technischen geräten
denn bislang gibt es einfach keinen
anderen elektrischen energiespeicher der
wiederaufladbar ist und vergleichbar
gute eigenschaften in der anwendung hat
aber fest steht auch für die gewinnung
und bereitstellung der benötigten
rohstoffe wie lithium selbst nickel
mangan und kobalt als elektrodenmaterial
gehen große umweltrisiken aus genau
deswegen suchen forschungsteams weltweit
nach möglichkeiten um
hochleistungsfähige speichermaterialien
zu entwickeln die auf nachwachsenden
rohstoffen basieren diesen plan sind
jetzt wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler des karlsruher instituts
für technologie kit näher gekommen
denn sie haben entdeckt dass das molekül
für ihn die ladegeschwindigkeit von
batterien deutlich in die höhe treibt im
labor wurden speicherkapazitäten von 130
bis 170 milliarden stunden programm
gemessen
bei einer mittleren spannung von 3 volt
die be- und entladung dauer lag dabei
bei nur einer minute wow das
forschungsteam ist optimistisch die
speicherkapazität um weitere
100 milliarden stunden programm zu
steigern zudem ist der plan den speicher
neben lithium auch mit natrium zu
betreiben
dies würde die batterieherstellung sehr
viel nachhaltiger machen den atrium ist
als rohstoff deutlich häufiger verfügbar
das organische molekül namens purr für
ihn ist im übrigen keineswegs unbekannt
im gegenteil ist es in der natur sehr
verbreitet dieses molekül bildet das
grundgerüst von chlorophyll also dem
blattgrün zudem ist es auch das gerüst
des blutfarbstoffs von mensch und tier
auch hämoglobin genannt und zudem bildet
es auch die basis von vitamin b12 und
die leistungssteigerung in den
laborexperimenten kann sich wirklich
sehen lassen dazu maximilian fichtner
einer der beteiligten forscher
die speicher eigenschaften sind
außergewöhnlich war das material eine
speicherkapazität wie eine batterie
material besitzt aber so schnell
arbeitet wie ein super kondensator
letzterer weisen zwar nur etwa zehn
prozent der energiedichte von
konventionellen akkus auf dabei ist ihre
leistungsdichte bis zu hundertfach
größer so dass sie sehr viel schneller
und entladen werden können um diese
eigenschaft zu erreichen versetzte das
forschungsteam aus karlsruhe das
organische molekül kupfer porphyry mit
organischen gruppen diese führten dazu
dass sich das material in der
batteriezelle strukturell und elektrisch
vernetzt die struktur der elektroden
wurde so extrem stabilisiert mehrere
tausend lade und entladezyklen wurden
wie möglich gemacht wenn er immer als
erstes neues zum thema
batterietechnologie und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
nummer hier von whatsapp hier der link
bei euch dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen von mir vom neuesten video
direkt wenn es hochgeladen wurde
garantiert er könnten direkt in der
redaktion von blick so mitmachen und mit
themen vorschlagen oder über
abstimmungen mitbestimmen was hierbei
clixoom läuft einfach da drauf kriegen
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
auch dafür draufklicken elektroautos
revolutionäres neues batterie konzept
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran